what does it mean to you guys to be the
first male same-sex couple on 90 day
fiancé is how important is this
visibility on a popular franchise like
that well to us it's really important
because we want to show true love you
want to show that two men can be in love
that they can have families above is
love and same-sex relationships are just
like everybody else's it's not always
Romeo and Juliet it can be Romeo and
Romeo yeah this man has got it all
beautiful smile beautiful eyes his body
is great we met on a social media page
it was a support group for gay fathers
have you been able to keep track of
audience reaction have people reached
out to you saying how they've been
affected by what they've seen so far
we've actually got a lot of those
already that are really saying you know
you guys are great and you really open
my mind and they were having trouble
struggling like when their son came out
or their daughter came out and they're
seeing that they can have a great life
and they can fall in love with somebody
of the same sex and have an amazing
relationship what's your take on the
whole experience of exposing your story
and exposing your life and all of these
ups and downs that you're going through
to all these people watching
do you think he'll approve of us I think
he would approve of us
I'm just worried about our safety people
in Mexico are still homophobic it all
has been a learning process
you know meshing the cultures together
you have an age difference but all in
all I think you know being there for
each other and understanding each other
through it all has brought us even
closer together we're a team with this
do the good and the bad that we have
each other's back and we're just a team
through the whole thing we've already
seen a lot of emotional moments europa'
stolen evidence akira Nino let's
continue and what can we expect in the
rest of the season coming up
there's a lot going to be happening
there's a lot more emotions where you
can tell were very emotional people a
lot more tears there's a lot of
happiness there's a lot of struggles as
well but there are things that happen
that surprised us and a lot of
roadblocks to get to this point that
we're at right now